[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau rendez vous du 7 8
sociétés dans ce magazine nous débattons
discutons en réfléchissant sur les
sujets qui font l actualité en 2016 un
reportage de complément d'enquêté
magazine de france 2 révélé que près de
la moitié des sportifs partant aux jeux
olympiques de rio vivaient avec moins de
500 euros par mois des athlètes non
rémunérés par leur fédération et
pourtant pourvoyeur de résultats voire
deux médailles une loin en 2015 leur a
donné un statut juridique et des
collectivités les soutiennent parfois
financièrement alors pourquoi cet
engagement on en parle avec nos invités
laurent mazaury bonsoir
qu'on aperçoit
vice président délégué aux sports de
saint quentin en yvelines dominique
modeste bonsoir
si le maire adjoint délégué aux sports
de la ville de plaisir montant oui
bonsoir
et lunel je vous en prie et lionel vast
bonsoir bonsoir le maire de la ville
d'andrésy alors avant que nous
échangions trouve où tous les quatre je
vous propose qu'on regarde un sujet
c'est une liste non exhaustive
d'athlètes soutenu par les collectivités
qu'ils aient déjà participé aux jeux
comme les derniers qui ont lieu à tokyo
ou qu'il représente l'avenir de l'équipe
de france regardez
[Musique]
oh
pour vous
[Musique]
bonjour
oh
laurent mazaury je vais commencer avec
vous donc ça quand on est vide on l'a vu
dans le sujet a soutenu quatre athlètes
de trois sports différents est ce qu'il
ya une sélection pour ces soutiens
alors ça quand on évite de parler statut
qui sont nôtres et nos compétences nous
avons une forme de soutien qui est
automatique ce qui concerne le haut
niveau et dont nous exprimons stricto
sensu donc denses qui a été délibérée
par eddy par les élus dans ce cadre-là
savoir qu'en 2021 au total au total ont
versé plus de trois cent dix mille euros
de subvention au titre du haut niveau
donc avec ce sont quand même des sommes
qui sont conséquentes pour un territoire
comme le nôtre avec un total complet
pour et textuellement exhaustive de 47
sportifs qui ont été soutenues le tout
dans plus de 17 club saint quentinois
vous voyez que c'est très très important
et on se réfère tout simplement aux
listes sont édités par le ministère des
sports et qui classe les sportifs de
haut niveau en quatre catégories
sociales que vous connaissez
certainement les espoirs les collectifs
nationaux ce qu'on appelle la relève les
seniors et l'élite et se rajoute à cela
à sa longue de soutien supplémentaires
en fonction des sélections effectivement
qui ont lieu pour les jeux olympiques de
tokyo où on retrouve là les quatre
sportifs que vous que vous citez dont
d'ailleurs un jeu tient à rappeler à une
médaille de bronze et donc vous voyez
que le soutien s'exerce à la fois dans
un cadre strict choisi par les élus mais
également avec une adaptation sur ces
sportifs là quand ils sont sélectionnés
pour concourir aux jeux olympiques et je
pense que ça sera le cas dès leurs
premiers jo de 2024 c'est un soutien
purement financiers ce sont des
infrastructures qui sont mises à
disposition une aide d'un autre genre
peut-être alors évidemment vous avez
raison de souligner quand on a les
infrastructures qui permettent de les
mettre à disposition ces faits à travers
entre autres les fédérations évidemment
bien sûr manière très emblématique je
citerai le vélodrome nationale qui sert
d'entraînement là pour le coup aussi
bien aux équipes d'heure de saint
quentin cau équipe nationale qui
s'entraînent de fête nationale mais
c'est également valide pour le golf
entre autres on va très bientôt
inaugurer tous ensemble l'école
nationale de golf qui accueille
l'ensemble des golfeurs en devenir
français et de fête saint quentinois
après bien sûr il faut avoir des
infrastructures pour permettre ces
différents différentes perfectionnement
ce cheminement du haut niveau ce soir
religion ou pas pour les jo et là c'est
un travail que l'on fait avec tous les
élus de saint quentin entre autres sur
la partie investissement c'est bien de
financer des investissements ils
répondent aux attentes du haut niveau
mais ne l'oublions pas aussi le haut
niveau c'est ce qui tire la pratique
amateur et le sport santé et donc on
fait toujours un équilibre entre cette
volonté de perfectionnement de haut
niveau et comme emblème et comme soutien
et qui en élément moteur pour le sport
du quotidien le sport de l'ensemble des
lionel vast votre soutien lui a été vers
un para badistes merrill loket qui est
partie aux jeux paralympiques de tokyo
c'est un jeune andrésiens de 24 ans
comment vous en êtes vous venu à le
soutenir
déjà nous on n'est pas une communauté
urbaine de 230 mille habitants comme
saint quentin en yvelines elle est une
modeste ville de 13 mille habitants on
fait avec avec nos moyens alors c'est
sûr que notre avantage à nous c'est
comme on est quand même beaucoup moins
nombreux
on décrypte très facilement et
rapidement les nos sportifs de haut
niveau et en l'occurrence oui voilà nous
avions un un champion de france de
paraboles minton
champion d'europe de parabène badminton
et qui a donc été qualifiée qui est
partie aux jeux olympiques de tokyo donc
nous avons été amenés à lui proposer une
subvention pour l'aider dans son voyage
à tokyo parce que les sportifs
paralympiques ont encore plus de
difficultés en termes financières en
termes logistiques en termes
d'accompagnement donc on lui a fait une
subvention avec nos modestes moyens de
quelques milliers d'euros
et nous les nous l'aidons aussi dans nos
infrastructures sportives on a notamment
une très belle infrastructure sportive
le complexe diagana dans lequel on lui
avait réservé des créneaux
d'entraînement avant de partir aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo oui j'imagine que
c'était peut-être presque salutaire pour
lui
juste avant que les tokio zh les gigots
pardon soit décalée d'un mois en raison
de la crise sanitaire les athlètes ont
vu de nombreuses compétitions s'annuler
des salles fermées j'imagine que
peut-être pour merrill loket les changes
étaient deux est-ce que je peux utiliser
pour continuer à me maintenir aussi en
forme
pendant confinement il a été un des
rares sportifs à pouvoir encore accéder
à tous les équipements de la ville et
notamment aux dans le dans le gymnase
donc c'est lui a permis effectivement de
continuer son anciennement alors là on a
parlé d'athlètes qui sont déjà qu'ils
ont fait les titres des journaux que
soient locaux nationaux le sport ça a
commencé très tôt il faut les soutenir
souvent très longtemps à l'avancé et à
plaisir le soutien et talent est une
jeune gymnaste ça s'appelle maylis la
porte elle a 15 ans elle est licenciée
au gère elancourt maurepas elle
s'entraîne à l'insep et en équipe de
france dominique modeste il faut aussi
se tourner vers l'avenir
à tout à fait tout à fait faux il faut
les soutenir dès le plus jeune âge tous
ceux qui sont repérés qui sont
potentiellement
porteurs de performance
il faut vraiment les soutenir et lorsque
les parents 2010 puisqu'elle est c'est
une jeune athlète sont venus nous voir
nous avons été heureux de les recevoir
et de pouvoir les aider puisque nous la
ville de plaisir a signé une convention
avec
malice la porte qui a intégré l'insep au
mois de septembre dernier et qui nous
l'espérons tous accédera l'équipe de
france pour les prochains jeux
olympiques qui seront chez l'une est la
ville a décidé donc de la soutenir
c'était pour nous c'était une évidence
c'est un soutien financier pour vous
aussi c'est un soutien d'infrastructure
je ne sais pas c'est pas à côté non plus
comment ça s'organise alors c'est un
soutien essentiellement financier
puisqu'elle est d'intégrer l'insep et en
fait elle suit une formation c'est très
très stricte
nous nous l'aidons financièrement parce
que
son parcours à l'insep est assez onéreux
ça on ne sait pas trop où on est tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé des sportifs
mais beaucoup de sportifs est justement
de faire de rémunération dont il
pourrait bénéficier
[Musique]
est somme toute c'est un coût qui est
assez important et bien sûr il faut les
aider
d'ailleurs vous allez parler des villes
les collectivités territoriales qui les
aidaient il ya aussi des administrations
parce que je pense à la gendarmerie à la
douane aussi qui qui ont des sportifs
qui ont intégré des sports cliff au
sound station oui l'armée à son équipe
des champions un parmi lesquels martin
fourcade qu'est le nom le plus célèbre
qui me vient à l'esprit sur le mot quand
on vous entend c'est surtout un rêve un
appui financier c'est presque un
paradoxe que les sportifs de haut niveau
c'est leur métier actuellement même
s'ils sont amateurs à vous entendre les
collectivités doivent les aider je ne
sais pas qui veut se lancer
monsieur mazaury peut-être oui mais il
n'ya pas il faut être très très clair si
on veut avoir du sport de haut niveau il
faut aux sportifs de haut niveau soit
dans des conditions mentales et
techniques et au quotidien de soutien
complexe sinon aucun sport est d'autant
plus qu'une section des sports
individuels ne peuvent permettre de le
pratiquer de s'y entraîner s'il n'y a
pas des soutiens et en moyens et en
matériel parce que le sportif doit être
concentrée exclusivement sur la
performance mais plus que tout autre il
ne doit pas avoir à sico logiquement
intégrer des contraintes extérieures qui
vient va tenir à ses performances et en
cela les collectivités territoriales et
monsieur vanneste a raison de le dire
aussi les eaux les supports sur
invitation mais aussi aux entreprises
privées qui bien souvent soutien des
sportifs sont essentiels à créer un
écosystème du succès ou que le sportif
soit tourné vers son sport et qui n'ont
qu'il n'est pas les soutiens les soucis
du quotidien vous savez parfois c'est
très compliqué pour un sportif même de
très haut niveau autorisé un déplacement
sur le lieu où elle une pétition il faut
pouvoir l'aider dans son transport il
faut pouvoir l'aider dans son
hébergement sur place bien ça s'il n'ya
pas effectivement oui et des entreprises
et des collectivités territoriales et
rainbow lui il ne pourra pas le faire et
c'est valable bien entendu de la même
façon pour le handisport si demain une
soulte on pointe sportif je pense à ces
deux sites sabouraud par exemple à saint
quentin et bien probablement que cécile
sera en difficulté offert les
performances qu'elle est impossible et
de fait et je n'applique pas une veille
24 et ça c'est valable sur tous les
niveaux de sport ça marche aussi sur le
sport par équipes par exemple on n'en
parle pas assez mais on a aussi des
équipes je pense d'ailleurs et je salue
mes amis de plaisir pour la partie rugby
on a aussi des grands clubs sur nos
territoires si on ne soutient pas assez
sport par équipes saint quentin c'est
plus de 113 1500 euros de subventions
financières et bien nos équipes ne
seront pas pour le coup c'est le cas de
le dire essentiellement au niveau
lionel vast est ce que quand vous signer
un partenariat avec merrill look est il
est à une obligation de résultat ou vous
êtes vraiment là pour l'accompagner et
qu'ils puissent être aux plus hautes ses
capacités à notre niveau donc une
commune de 13 mille habitants il n'y a
pas d'obligation de résultat de
résultats il est déjà là voilà il est
déjà un niveau exceptionnel donc pour
nous c'est déjà une très grande fierté
pour compléter ce que disait monsieur
mazaury le soutien ne se limite pas bien
évidemment à des finances ou à la
possibilité d'utiliser nos équipements
publics c'est aussi un soutien en termes
de moyens humains on a mis à la
disposition de merrill look est
champion paralympique notre service de
communication pour valoriser son image
et nous avons bien évidemment aussi
utiliser notre réseau politique pour
justement contacté d'autres
collectivités territoriales au dessus de
nous et je pense à la communauté urbaine
à laquelle ge à andrésy appartient pour
essayer justement de d'approfondir ce
soutien oui dominique modeste est ce que
c'est aussi maëlys devra à maylis
laporte pardon devra peut-être présente
pour la ville de plaisir aussi on sait
que alain bernard quand il s'est engagé
à la gendarmerie avait des frais de
représentation des moments de
représentation à faire c'est souvent ce
qui est signé avec l'armée est ce que
dans cette convention les associés ou à
15 ans vous la laissez encore évoluer
dans son parcours de d'athlète
pour l'instant les suivants nous et bien
sûr dans son corps d'athlète parce que
son parcours d'athlète se conjugue aussi
avec un parcours scolaire bien
évidemment parce que les carrière de
l'athlète sont assez courtes et il faut
aussi privilégier cette partie là donc
nous
n'imposons rien bien évidemment c'est
une jeune athlète qui viennent d'être
détectée qui s'entraîne donc comme je le
disais à l'insep et si bien sûr nos
espoirs reposent sur elle mais je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus trop leur mettre
la pression il faut quand même qu'ils
vivent leur vie d'athlète tranquillement
les qu'ils puissent entraîner dans un
cadre serein
laurent mazaury l'avenir séparer de 1024
à 50 ans nue et va voir plusieurs
épreuves se déroulent et donc celles au
vélodrome nationale qui est aussi le
siège de la fédération française de
cyclisme
les partenariats ne vont justement pas
s'arrêter là vous l'avez vite fait
mentionner tout à l'heure
alors les personal s'arrêteront pas là
et c'est surtout que les jeux olympiques
de paille 2024 c'est un magnifique élan
sportif à la fois au four évidemment les
athlètes mais avant tout il est on y est
très attaché pour une population un ca
dépasse largement le cadre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je pense cette
année l'ordre national mais sur les
territoires des idées dans une chance
d'avoir beaucoup d'épreuves cette chance
d'avoir effectivement à saint quentin
vous avez raison de dire quatre épreuves
une réalité je ne peux pas trop en dire
plus mais je pense qu'on aura même 5
voilà donc même s'il n'a pas de le dire
je vous resterai vrai la surprise de la
5e et pont qui sera vraiment encore plus
populaires qui tentait que c'est
possible que les quatre autres parce que
ce qui est important c'est que derrière
jeux olympiques il ya le sport il ya
l'aménagement du territoire a parce
qu'évidemment c'est un investissement
important en terme d'aménagement et à la
partie héritage vous savez que la partie
l état je crois que mes deux collègues
élus ils sont très attachés c'est qui
c'est aussi une manière de donner
ensuite à l'ensemble de la population
des infrastructures à l'élan sportif qui
permet de bénéficier à tous et on est
très longue en cela de ce qui se passait
il ya encore une quinzaine d'années où
bien souvent on critiquait les jeux
olympiques dans d'autres pays en disant
mais qu'est ce qu'il en reste et il en
restait souvent des équipements à
l'abandon des sports qui était peu
pratiquée les habitants pareil 2024 et
dans les yvelines il ya ce soit des
équipements d'avoir une grosse partie
existe et ce qui n'existe pas ce ne sera
qu'une d'elancourt seront demain ouvert
au grand public pour que tout le monde
puisse pratiquer le sport à son niveau
il n'y a pas de ya pas de grand et de
bas sport tous les sports sont bons ils
doivent tous être un ticket quel que
soit son niveau et là nous les élus
locaux monsieur maudet de suivre ce
thème nous sommes là pour ça je fais en
sorte que ce sport c'est un blague du
sport puisse bénéficier au plus grand
nombre c'est en cela qu'ils avaient
nommé de 24 sera un élan pour le futur
extraordinaire comme l'ont été
probablement les jeux olympiques d'hiver
à l'époque où ils ont lieu en france et
vous disais oh sees 47 sportif essieux
de 17 clubs saint quentinois
subventionné est ce que vous allez
chercher en subventionner plus pour les
années à venir sans nécessairement
parler paris 2024
comme je voulais dit en réalité le nul
dans cette dans cette partie de la
subvention de nous sommes en attente que
nos sportives nos équipes et de nos
sportifs individuels progressent pour
rentrer dans nos critères d'attribution
de subventions et j'irai que
l'appartement où ils atteignent le haut
niveau ces critères sont quasiment
automatique se rajoutent bien entendu
parcours de la sélection et jeux
olympiques et plus nous allons deux
sportives qui sont sélectionnés pour les
jo et plus bien entendu nous rajouterons
de l'assistance au niveau financier mais
également et comme l'a dit mon collègue
lionel bien entendu avec d assistance
concrète du quotidien les laines aux
appareils un instant de la communication
mais c'est par exemple du matériel c'est
par exemple de la visibilité
supplémentaire c'est de l'assistance
aller chercher d'autres sponsors puisque
on a cette chance à saint-quentin
d'avoir un tissu économique
exceptionnelle ça nous permet lors de
moments particuliers de porter ces
sportifs pour les mettre en relation
avec des sponsors du monde de
l'entreprise et tout cela c'est le rôle
d'une agglomération comme ça quand on
est l'idée c'est vrai qu'on a la chance
d'avoir des moyens financiers importants
en ce moment à une population importante
et un tissu d'entreprises également très
dynamique lionel vast j'imagine que vous
allez continuer à suivre merrill loket
oui mais si on va continuer à le suivre
d'une part et d'autre part c'est vrai
que pour nous ça a été un tremplin pour
aller plus loin que ça nous sommes une
ville labellisée terre de jeux 2024 et
au sein de faire grâce à ce label en
fait on va aussi rendre on va aussi
travailler sur sur ce qu'on doit faire à
savoir le service public on a peut être
une mairie qui va éduquer qui va
sensibiliser aux sports et à l'handicap
on va profiter de ce sportif pour
proposer une journée du handicap sur la
ville et on a aussi
conventionnés avec merrill des
rencontres avec tous nos scolaires pour
justement parler du sport du haut niveau
et parler du handicap sportive donc oui
voilà c'est pour nous un vrai un vrai
tremplin et toutes ces actions vont
perdurer jusqu'aux jeux olympiques à
paris c'est la commission municipale qui
va être d'aider ce projet là oui c'est
la commission municipale qui va être
dédié à cela les et lui travaillent en
étroite collaboration avec avec notre
sportif de haut niveau et bien sûr en
entrant partenariat très étroit avec
toutes nos toutes nos écoles primaires
dominique modeste à plaisir aussi où
vous pensez que cette convention va
pousser les peut-être les jeunes plaisir
aux à s'intéresser à plus de sport à la
jeunesse et de rythmiques on en parle
presque finalement comme jai ho
oui alors c'est vrai alors
malheureusement on a plaisir nous
n'avons pas de gymnastique rythmique
parce qu'il faut être affilié à la
fédération française et puis
notre club est affilié à l'ufolep
ce qui était rien de très bon niveau 6 1
mais bien sûr de toute façon chaque
athlète qui
réussit dans son sport qui ramène les
médailles même s'il n'en mène pas même
s'il est bien classé 6e place bien sâr
mène évidemment énormément demande
énormément d'adhérents énormément
d'adhésion dans les clubs sportifs que
nous nous avons vu cette année à la fête
des associations tous les sports
collectifs et notamment les sports
collectifs de sable on fait vraiment le
plein malgré les conditions sanitaires
que nous connaissons ils ont fait le
plein parce que les résultats étaient
excellents donc c'est vraiment un
ça dynamise en fait complètement un
sport
les sports collectifs ont fait une belle
razzia aux jo de tokyo je vous propose
que nous nous arrêtions sur ces mots
bien sûr le regard est tourné vers paris
2024 et notamment tous nos athlètes yves
binois dont on n'a pas parlé ne
serait-ce qu'à l'exportation autres
nageurs saint germanois je vous propose
que c'est cette société se termine sur
ses propos je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et
d'ici là bien sûr portez vous bien
[Musique]